with baron somebody just been released
as a playable god in smite now seems
like a perfect time to discuss some
Haitian and voodoo myth now for those of
you much like myself who may be
unfamiliar voodoo was believed to have
originated in French slave colonies in
the 18th century these slave colonies
are forced to convert to Christianity
and had many of their own religious
beliefs and practices suppressed as a
result of this voodoo became a mixture
of everything embracing elements from
the Yoruba and Bakongo in Africa while
also incorporating an idea of European
spirituality even being influenced by
Freemasonry and European mysticism so
now we can move on to the bulk with a
video discussing the Baron himself Baron
Samedi is just one of the many lower of
Haitian of Voodoo the lower being spirit
like deities but rather than them being
worshipped or prayed to they are instead
served these lower will have their own
unique identities their own preferences
likes and dislikes
they have different symbols different
songs dances and rituals and quite often
they possess human beings as a means of
acquiring a physical body they aren't
however always refer to as literal
deities like we see in Greek Roman or
Egyptian myth instead they are spirits
messengers to the supreme creator in the
eyes of Voodoo as' the unknowable good
got Bondi Baron Samedi whose name in
French means Baron Saturday was
considered the lure of the dead along as
many incarnations bounce MIT a bow on
Lacroix and balan chemin el fortunately
for those of you watching this video who
are indeed French that is the first and
last time I'll be attempting a French
accent in this video the Baron was
considered the head of the get a family
who a group of spirits had embodied the
powers of death and fertility
interestingly enough the Barons wife
maman Bridget or mother Bridget in
English was often symbolized by a black
rooster and protected the gravestones
and cemeteries that were marked of a
cross mother Bridget is often described
as having red hair and emerald green
eyes and as her name would suggest she
originated from Island
making her the only white deity that we
see in voodoo the Baron himself is often
depicted as a tall handsome black man
wearing a top hat and a black tuxedo
he's faced his white and quite skeletal
looking at times he has cotton plugs in
each nostril reflecting a common
practice in Haitian burials
along with his signature cane Baron
Samedi always has an abundance of cigars
and alcohol the Getae family were
traditionally seen as loud rude and
quite sexual many considered them to be
a lot of fun and the Baron was no
different being known for his dancin
obscenity disruption and debauchery so
what exactly does Baron Samedi do other
than drink rum smoked cigars and have
sex to start off it's believed that no
spirit could cross into the realm of the
dead without being accepted by Baron
Samedi when an individual would die
Samedi would dig their grave and then
greet their soul once they had been
buried and eventually lead them to the
underworld despite being a spirit
associated with the dead he was also
seen as one that could give life and
heal those in need many saw Baron Samedi
as a symbol of reincarnation not only
with the power to give the dead new life
but to save those who would inch away
from dying when it came to those who
thought they had been a victim of the
hex or some kind of black magic they
would look towards the Baron as it was
said if he refused to dig their grave
they could not die the Baron could also
cure any disease or wound known to
mankind now I mentioned earlier the
Baron had several different incarnations
and since they will have their own
unique mannerisms and behavior we can
take a look at the differences between
them Baron Samedi was known for spending
most of his time in between our room and
the Invisibles spirit realm baron
Lacroix
which means Baron of the cross was seen
as suave and sophisticated not much of a
party animal but rather a philosopher of
death Baron simatai heir was the male
guardian of the cemetery along with his
wife who we discussed earlier what I
found most interesting about this
iteration was the belief that his horses
will also wear a tuxedo and a top hat
but it doesn't quite stop there they
also demonstrated behavior quite similar
to their master smoking cigars and drink
and finally Kerr baron criminal was one
of the most feared lower he was seen as
a murderer condemned to death and when
he was invoked he would provide swift
judgement this iteration of the Baron
was the least pleasant to be around when
someone was possessed by Baron criminal
they would shout obscenities and attempt
to harm all of those around them one of
the ways to appease this particular
spirit was with the sacrifice of black
chickens by burning them alive as it was
believed the shrieking of the chickens
when being burned appealed to his cruel
nature
I do find barren somebody rather
interesting because he has a fairly
large and important role and you do must
expect his personality to reflect that
but instead you have someone who's
notorious for his outrageous behavior
constantly partying and drinking but yet
he still remains capable of performing
his duty and to me that feels very
human-like in the same way many of us
work extremely hard but then also party
hard in our spare time
so does Baroness Emma D it's definitely
been interesting looking into some
voodoo and I'm sure many of you will be
able to shed some light and a lot of the
things that were covered in this video
so as always feel free to share any
thoughts and stories you may have
regarding the Baron in the comments
below I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained